so because we just played a lot of spell
chess there's no jumping or freezing in
this game
but there are a lot of like new pieces
put this on my layout hang on yeah it
might require some redesign I'm a big
boy
all right okay I'm assuming okay got a
lot of distance here to cover but that's
okay okay so all the pieces should be
somewhat self-explanatory like there's a
combination of Knight and Bishop and
Knight and rook and then queen and king
what the hell is that the thing that I
just moved is called the camel it moves
up three and over one as opposed to up
to and over one like a knight I have a
camel whoa
these are just
Queen these are just like my knight with
a queen is just a queen wearing a night
costume essentially so it moves like a
queen and a knight combined yeah so it's
probably like the most powerful piece
oh I probably shouldn't have taken him
out first so uh it's it's an interesting
opening strategy camels
yeah you can't jump over my pawn and
take the king I know
yes yeah it's
much more similar to normal chess yeah
there's checking checkmates
this is
uh don't speak too soon
check what
I forgot you could do that I thought you
could it's important to have board
Vision it's so easy to miss like a
square or a line more Division and
camera vision everything you need in
life
okay no mercy oh
so this is interesting if I take your
Pawn which looks undefended
you take back with your camel
very very tricky my camel
right oh no man yes
face
ah my camel is so strong I think next
time we want to play with the camel
camel defense
he's trying to bring his camel out so I
need to use my camels to defend
and camels have kind of a similar
property as Bishops like you have a dark
squared one and a light squared one okay
a nice
I like these silly looking camels
here we can ask Magnus How the Camel
moves chat
you won't know that one
oh yeah
if he ever attends a world championship
press conference again
true
never comes such
ah
I can now
camel's coming
where's your camel going his camel is
here here he's got nothing on him with a
picture of everything
my camel can come out too you're not the
only one
want to threaten a checkmate
maybe something like sneaky
gotta be sneaky
okay I'm gonna use I actually like this
very I'm glad you showed me this
thank you yeah it's it's very
mind-bending I'm trying to figure out
how to
[Music]
yeah that's it that's the Big Dipper
right there
bang camel there threading this and then
we do some crazy stuff like this oh yes
I'm restricting your camel with my camel
I'm pinning your camel
your camel is oh wow you skewered mine
quite
your connites is now in danger well I'm
gonna
Donnie Bishop is stronger than the camel
in this game
hmm
this is upsetting
my plan
my plan has been foiled I have nothing
now except a ton of stupid camels
got a couple camels
okay so you just you just gave me your
camel you you've attacked my camel
but camels attack each other
and your canites is pinned by my quite
[Music]
almost smothered camel mate
hang on
hang on not yet
surely damn it I forgot your tonight
your camel was defending my
uh it's it's very confusing hitting my
king
exactly I think
and if I do this so just think I've
heard this song so many times the
listings and updates
hmm okay we need to find something
tricky chat
there's got to be something
audio sounds like Chess Masters having a
stroke now that was a tricky one he
really really tricked us there I'm
pretty sure you only have one legal move
in this position
I didn't realize I was in jail
[Music]
is that
it takes some adjusting it used to How
the Camel moves
[Music]
um
don't know it goes somewhere interesting
it's not this is not wizard chess I
don't know
okay oh wait oh this is crazy I don't
know if he sees this I'm not gonna say
it
I'm not gonna share this one but there's
a secret right now I don't know what I'm
supposed to see
I'll show chat
um
I don't think he knows
I don't think he knows they can do this
no idea what you're threatening I mean I
know that you're threatening my camel
but
he knows he's on to us he's on he's
looking for counter-attacks
okay let's
be solid
counter attack here
all right Miss Maiden won my
took my
call this
my I think I think officially it's
called the Amazon I just call it a quite
like the queen plus Knight equals quite
better
I'm very focused I don't know what it
made I mean I'm not talking yet but
we're coming in oh
one day
we're gonna meet him
oh right now his Bishop
damn this is this was silly of me
because now you just got all this free
Tempo I'm yeah you you developed you're
quite too early I'm just attacking it
with my other pieces you know
you know I see now
we're trying to try
to travel chats
trying to trap his camel yeah for
everyone just tuning in uh this is a new
update to chess
Welcome To The Future
GM John ludvignale are you a hammer
impersonator
camera has really made it as his own
impersonators in chat now oh really
like camel traps no
chest 2.0
there's actually a chest 2.0 coming
the end is coming
uh
this game is so frustrating
your your camel makes me mad
I'm gonna say it that's uh that's the
goal of the camel thing anger the
opponent
s
the heckling camel
how do I use my pieces so they're full
potential
is pinning my thing let's uh let's
attack your camera
right oh I think Mr oh wait that's he
has a knife
um
I was thinking we could get creative
counter attack but ah
that was a flip
that was actually about slip that was
just a blender
I'm gonna take my camel please he's all
I have I would try and give you a take
back okay
because I'm a kind person
thank you I'll I'll let your camel
survive one more move you guys can
survive
yeah you have to be grateful for what
you have
um because I forget it I sometimes click
to try to see where the pieces go like a
Pog champ student
yeah there's actually a useful feature
to see the legal moves
okay next time it's over for you okay
this
all right we gotta do something with our
camel
but I don't know what to do with him to
be quite Frank
oh that's a free that's a free camel can
barely hang on to my camel yeah your
camel's not really attacking anything I
know it's this really sad I wish I could
sack
but then I would just be down in
material I would just be down to camels
watch your time
is this increment yes
there is a comment
okay
oh how to do this
there there
okay let's move my connect yeah these
these double night pieces are so strong
I'm gonna get my my Bishop out
my night's Bishop
why is my Spotify broken
one
okay chat oh you have all the only one
there goes your strongest piece
I want a rematch I want a Rego okay I
resigned that was a I I didn't I get it
now also my Spotify it takes some
adjusting yeah
intense gaming music hang on hang on
what do you listen to
um I'm just listening to The Sweet Sound
of Silence
that sounds terrible it's uh it's very
meditative at least when
it's actually silence
I give you a rematch okay I'm gonna play
uh same time control
okay okay good luck
thank you thank you this is called the
camel opening we're coming back
we're coming back we're gonna start with
our camel this is the camels Indian
actually
the camels Indian
fair enough
camel's coming out now that we know what
he does look at their camels they're
they're just talking to each other
you do have normal Bishops
it feels weird to have any
I think what you forgot about is
the camel's a very strong peace
and I'm gonna just end the game
immediately good game
it's the the camel jumps over things
yeah
that's smothered camels
well
[Music]